اعاد ميدان السياسه في تركيا الى التوتر
مجددا بعد قرار محكمه تركيه بسجن رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول المعارضه اكرم امام اوغلو
لمده سنتين و سبعه اشهر و 15 يوما اضافه
لحرمانه من العمل السياسي قبل اشهر قليله
فقط من انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه حاسمه
امام اوغلو عضو حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكبر
احزاب المعارضه اودين بتهمه اهانه اعضاء
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات بينما اكد
محاميه انه سيستانف القرار الذي لن يعتبر
نافذه قبل مصادقه محكمه الاستئناف
والمحكمه العليا
متابعه هذه المحكمه هذه القضيه دليل على
عدم وجود عداله في تركيا هذه القضيه
يقودها اشخاص لا يريدون تحقيق اسم القيم
مثل العداله والديمقراطيه للبلاد
قاده احزاب المعارضه والعديد من النقابات
والمنظمات المهنيه رفضوا قرار المحكمه
وتضامن مع امام كلو
اولا هذه ليست دعوه حقوقيه بل سياسيه
ثانيا هذه القضيه غير متوازنه ثالثا هذه
القضيه هي التقنيه من الانتخابات اسطنبول
التي لم يستطيع ان يفوزوا بها مرتين
سجن رؤساء البلديه ومسؤولين من هذه
الاحزاب والان يطبقون هذا الشيء
بعد بضعه اشهر من فوزه برئاسه بلديه
اسطنبول اعتبر اكرم امام اوغلو ان اولئك
الذين الغوا فوزه في الانتخابات اغبياء
مرددا عباره عن استخدامها وزير الداخليه
سليمان سولو ضده قبل بضع ساعات من هذا
التصريح الذي عرض رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
للملاحقه القضائيه بتهمه اهانه مسؤولين
حكومين لا شك ان عمليات التحضير
للانتخابات لن تكون كما كانت عليه قبل
قرار المحكمه بحق اكرم امام اوغلو والواضح
ان المعارضه ستستغل القرار بشكل كبير
حملاتها الانتخابيه خصوصا بين انصار حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم الذين صوت شطر
منهم لامام اوغلو في الانتخابات البلديه
الماضيه زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول